c'est une nouvelle qui pourrait
révolutionner la vie des malades et de
leurs familles
le 25 novembre 2019 l'organisme fédéral
américain de réglementation des produits
alimentaires et pharmaceutiques
la food and drug administration' publie
ce tweet
aujourd'hui nous avons approuvé un
nouveau traitement pour cible et
l'anomalie central de la maladie devait
être qu'un panneau si tu oses donnant
espoir à ceux qui vivent avec ce trouble
sanguin
une annonce qualifiée d' avancée majeure
pour soulager les personnes atteintes de
cette maladie génétique du sang
douloureuse et mortelle c'est une
entreprise biopharmaceutique
californienne qui a mis au point ce
traitement hawks bright assez son nom un
médicament qui sera destiné aux plus de
12 ans la fédération a accordé une
autorisation accéléré pour l'utilisation
de ce bras et à aux etats unis son
approbation s'appuie sur les résultats
d'un essai clinique mené auprès de 2 174
patients hawks brita devient donc le
quatrième traitement autorisé aux états
unis pour le traitement de la
drépanocytose
le médicament ne sera pas encore
disponibles pour les patients en europe
et dans le monde
rappelons qu'en martinique un peu plus
de 2000 personnes sont atteintes de
cette maladie génétique